you know people always say to me you and
Larry should be friends you and Larry I
get the same thing the same gu yeah I
get the same thing for years we would
say Howard this is you but Larry argue
why we shouldn't be friends uh I'm sure
because we're both deep down Despicable
people
right two miseries two miseries are you
I mean you're a legendary miserable Guy
The Story Goes third season of Seinfeld
you're of course the creator of Seinfeld
every reason in the world to be happy
the show is now successful and they come
to you and they say Larry the show has
been renewed for a third season and you
were in tears
yes it was too much pressure for you
right it's like a relationship I just
didn't think I could keep it up was it
an internal thing where you said Gee the
show is so important to people I don't
want to disappoint them I always felt
that well last year was so good how do
you top how do you top it and then I
started out the same thing on curb you
know oh boy that was a great season now
what do you think that these ideas that
you have that everyone seems to respond
to they're so Universal do you worry
they're just going to run out you know
how it's like when I drove a cab yes I
drop off a fair i' start driving around
he thought you'd never get another one
where's the next one there was nobody on
the street nobody's and I'd be racing
five other cabs down Second Avenue and
then somebody would raise their arm and
10 eight guys would cut me off are you
enjoying the experience at HBO with Curb
Your Enthusiasm you don't write an
actual script right right you come up
with scenarios and you tell everyone to
wing it exactly it's just stories and
then we improvise it once we get there
you know a lot of times we'll be doing
scenes and I won't even know what the
scene is until two minutes before Jeff
Garland will say to me what are we doing
I'll go I don't know let's find out most
of these episodes were really from your
everyday life when we look at Seinfeld
and we see the episode where George
decides to show up at work despite the
fact that he is mouthed off to his boss
now when you were a writer at Saturday
Night Live you mounted off to dick
ebersol he was the guy in charger wasn't
Lauren Michaels no you were hired as a
writer yes on Saturday Night Live you
were very discouraged and it's hard to
believe but none of your scripts were
ever chosen you were a failure at
Saturday Night Live total total failure
and you were there during that legendary
season when it was Billy Crystal and
Martin Short I mean what a great season
I thought it was one of their best
seasons you're not helping Larry by
saying it was a great season was not
represented Julia Louie drus yes that's
where I met
Allstar cast you're hired as a writer
you get in there within 5 weeks you're
completely irritated and disgusted with
the job right yes because they didn't
recognize your Genius am I correct my
sketches would do very well at the at
the read through at the dress ref yes
and then they would invariably get cut
like week after week after week and then
one night before the show I my another
sketch of mine was
cut and at 11:25 5 minutes before the
show was to start
um I had enough dick was sitting in his
in the chair and I marched over to him
probably didn't even know who you
were I watched over time I said this
[__] show stinks it
stinks it's [__] I'm done I'm gone [__]
this I'm out so you go home I'm I'm
walking home in the freezing cold
couldn't couldn't get a cab walking home
and I'm starting to compute how much
money I just cost myself right because
you had a year contract yeah the real
Kramer the guy you were living with
Kenny Kramer my next to her neighbor
right he says go back on Monday and
pretend like it didn't happen that's
exactly what I did I walked into the
meeting there was a r there's a rers
meeting every Monday morning and I
walked into the meeting the writers had
heard the Outburst right and I sat down
and then he would go around and ask
everybody what they were working on for
the week right and I was about the fifth
one on the couch and then he got to me
and I said well I'm thinking about doing
this circus sketch and nothing and you
had the job
yeah